[Applaudissements]
je t'amène langue avec moi ouais konami
nous en spectacle avec moi ou ça il ya
ya je sais pas il ya je pense va voir
huit spectacles je t'amène avec moi je
te tue vient de vous faire monter sur
scène à un moment et on passe toute la
soirée et la nuit je t'emmène avec moi
aussi là non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'espère arriver à 60 piges pour faire
des conneries pareilles
mais qu'est ce que ça fait du bien ça
c'est sans un cinéma c'est une jeune
fille qui en train de à
voilà d'éponger son voile et la lumière
se rallume le mec qui l'emmerdé tu vois
donc ils unis mais son chapeau sur sa
vite pour la cacher et la fille fait
semblant de chercher quelque chose par
terre et un petit but qui tape sur
l'épaule qui si vous cherchez l'habitat
sous le chapeau avec une meuf de quatre
mètres ou une nuit avec 4,9 de 1 m je
vais dire une connerie vous mener 4-2 à
m avec la tête plate pour poser le
verrou